si les embouteillages sont un fléau dans
de nombreuses grandes villes ce nouveau
rétropédalage concernant les deux roues
ne risque pas d'arranger la situation il
est désormais interdit de circuler entre
deux fils sous peine d'amendé depuis
2016 d'ile-de-france autorisé en effet
les motos et scooters à circuler entre
les voitures
une habitude qui est prise depuis bien
longtemps par les conducteurs de deux
roues pour éviter d'obstruer la
circulation et pouvoir se déplacer de
façon plus fluide dans les grandes
villes
l aventure qu'est ce que j'aimerais
pouvoir sauf que voilà cette règle était
en réalité une phase de test qui prendra
fin à compter du 1er février prochain
des motos et scooters devront donc
circuler comme des voitures c'est à dire
en file indienne un non sens pour les
motards qui risquent donc de ne pas
respecter cette règle beaucoup jugent
absurde
franchement c'est l'incompréhension
pourtant il pourra vous en coûter 3
points sur votre permis et 135 euros
d'amendé
si vous êtes arrêté en train de rouler
entre les voitures alors êtes vous
favorable à l'interdiction pour les
motos de circuler entre les voitures est
motos de circuler entre les voitures ça
a été le débat du jour c'est l'autre
quart d'heure sans fil regarder ça
réagit en gelée bois les gens quand on
conçoit motards ou pas alors gilles
verdez êtes d'accord et à stéphane qui
nous a rejoint stéphane plus tôt merci
steve
comment ça va commencer mes fans que je
connais donc je lui dit steph voilà ilan
un pote avec lui que je connaissais pas
c'est stéphane aussi ces deux motards a
envoyé un look de motards là on voit ya
du motard l'a lu on peut pas le début tu
ne vois pas du tout en voiture un peu
moins con moto le bon stéphane bien sûr
vous n'êtes pas favorable à ces deux
motards mais j'aimerais avoir l'avis du
oui ian dowie gilles verdez et nicolas
pernikoff je crois que les gars mari
alors là ça a été expérimenté il ya eu
des accidents alors moi perdre moi à
titre personnel mais on s'en fout
je trouve ça très compliqué d'avoir des
motos qui passe comme ça et j'ai vu deux
accidents quand même un des gens qui ont
changé des voitures qui ont changé de
file s'en faire gaffe aux motos donc en
l'occurrence qui est une expérimentation
qui n'a pas fonctionné en gironde il un
triplement les accidents dont moi je
suis légaliste et c'est vrai qu'il ya un
moment donné mais qu'est-ce que oui je
vous dise moi j'ai pas envie qu'il ait
des morts suite à des à des mauvaises
décisions qui ont été prises en ce n'est
pas juste pour vous emmerdez un nom dans
son bas c'est quand même alors gilles
verdez j'ai pris parfois des motos taxis
où on a slalomé et ben je vous le dis
plus jamais c'est trop dangereux mais
même pour vous les motards ses couloirs
ce sont les couloirs de la mort pour les
motos il ya l'angle mort qu'on appelle
vous ne voyez pas ce qui se passe les
voitures ne voit pas vous allez mourir
donc il faut interdire ça à tout jamais
il va y avoir de nouvelles
expérimentations même ça je suis contre
le bilan est définitif plus de motos qui
slalome fini d'avoir l'avis des deux
stéphane ce qui peut bien entendu moi
j'suis pas d'accord a bien sûr on doit
raison déjà un professionnellement si
vous avez vous êtes un taxi moto
d'accord d'accord comme monsieur verdez
l'a dit et c'est pas une attaque contre
ou il m'est arrivé de vous transporter
parce que vous étiez sur des sur des
temps très court effectivement on l'a
fait mais je pense qu'on a fait aussi en
sécurité parce que on demande à vous si
vous avez l'habitude pas l'habitude si
vous avez des craintes et jusqu'à
présent grâce à vous qui êtes quand même
arrivé en temps et en heure d'accord
maintenant on est tous suivant que ce
soit automobilistes moto je peux être je
ne peux faire une fausse manoeuvre ça
peut m'arriver comme un automobiliste
pour adresser aussi fait voudrait dire
un truc moi à chaque fois que je prends
une moto je me dis il faut avoir quand
même vraiment confiance en l'être humain
attention c'est pas vous vous pour être
le meilleur vautard du monde
en vrai si vous tombez sur un mec qui
est qui qui voit pas de voiture et les
mecs en voiture et que le téléphone sur
les quais non
fois en france est un vrai nom mais
c'est ça stéphane il faut avoir
mine de rien une confiance absolue tout
a dit un mec qui déboîte même si tu es
la meilleure on se côtoie ce secteur
franchement tu t'es hyper attention je
suis pas le meilleur mais on est obligé
de faire attention
sinon voilà on ne pourra pas transporter
des personnes en moto si on roulait
comme des fous que nous conviendrons
tombe par la tête en regardant à droite
à gauche maintenant pour moi même étant
petit son avoir jamais possédé perdre
une moto et un petit j'ai toujours connu
les motos qui remontaient les films il y
avait beaucoup beaucoup d'accidents
stéphane note stéphane qui sinon ouais
bah ouais de au final c'est plus les
voitures quand on parle de des accidents
de voiture qui déboule et qui tape la
moto c'est la période à l'automobiliste
les au téléphone ou au chief un kick et
dans ses pensées qui regardent ailleurs
donc c'est pas là mais pas la route
c'est pour la sécurité des motards au 6
mai oui mais voilà reste excusez moi à
ce moment-là pourquoi on nous en cours
nous donnerait pas une file réservée
pour les pour les motards et alors ça
peut te ring pourquoi ça oui on
regardait quand on n'en parlait s'il n'y
a pas un bus dans une voie de bus qui
est pourquoi nous on nous empêcherait de
prendre sept votes celle-ci d'accord à
s'interdire le périph
il ya des voies de telle heure à telle
heure pour les taxis qui sont réservées
pourquoi on ne serait pas à pas pouvoir
les nationalisant rebondissent à la
voyait justement contre la chaîne de
droite et celle du milliard mais vous
aviez à un moment donné vous avez droit
de rouler sur les red bull ont été dans
le droit ce à quoi je vais les personnes
qui disent oui sur moi qui sont pour
cette interdiction
alors moi je mets oui pourquoi parce
qu'en plus je suis venu en moto à
l'émission et franchement il ya beaucoup
de ça passe ou ça casse et moelle et ça
passe ou ça casse ça me fait trop trop
trop flipper moi je trouve ça pas normal
qu'on puisse faire autant confiance à
des gens qui ne savent pas conduire
et là je trouve que c'est dangereux et
c'est ça que j'ai réussi leur jeu si oui
pourquoi ils pourraient pas les laisser
rouler je vous avoue qu'avec mon
chauffeur on a pris une voie de bus et
balas et sf et là je me suis donc oui je
suis pour la voie de bus mais par contre
remonter les files moi ça me fait
vraiment trop flipper est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu des accidents s'étaient pas
d'ester personnellement ou non j'avais
stéphane très bon non non non en tout
cas jamais avec un client ça m'est
arrivé une fois de me déporter de
monsieur rechuter par une autre moto ah
oui ça m'est arrivé une fois mais je
vous parle de ça il ya disons et vous
stéphane non on tâte personnel oui
mais pas fin sur route mais pas en pente
hac si vous envoyant gilles verdez ce
que je veux dire c'est que stéphane et
des équipes aux équipes vous êtes de
grands professionnels
mais combien d'amateurs combien de gens
qui eux ne savent pas vraiment bien
piloté par combien de gens qui vont trop
vite qui dépassait 50 km heure combien
de gens qui dépassent cette limite
regardez benjamin castaldi trois tweets
on dit aussi qu'on se réveille un peu en
régie tient des tweets en direct ou en
direct c'est pas pour enfiler des perles
merci dommage j'aurais mis m oui parce
que je devais je suis pour alors vous
avez raison on est sûrs oui mais
justement j'ai dit non et parce que je
suis la première à utiliser des motos
taxis mais bon on est poussé à aller
vite parce que sinon j'arrive en retard
mais pas si je suis bien ces deux là et
il me transporte notamment le stéphane
qui est le plus proche de vous oui mais
transmissible
oui oui mais bon je suis en confiance
absolue et ce car oui quand j'ai pas été
en confiance était aussi de mauvais
c'est pour ça que je vous adore isabelle
mashaei on parle pas de la soie seynois
qui est en train de passer et on parle
de tous les motards on parle pas que des
motos taxis ou les enterrements
mais oui mais alors mais alors alors
allez allez allez allez sur automoto oui
je sais bien qu'on érige des doigts mais
encore faut-il qu'elle soit réaliste et
respecté à moi j'ai un ami qui est moto
taxi qui me dit que personne ne va
respecter cette loi à un des seuls
d'intérêt de la moto ce comme d'aller
plus vite que la voie d'accès très vite
voire très dur de circuler dans les
grandes villes en voiture et cela pas
mettre votre votre métier en danger
aussi le fait mention aussi des journées
dans les voitures là où je suis d'accord
avec lorsque votre ami a dit c'est que
déjà l'intérêt d'étendre ou si on doit
stationner derrière les voies du
caractère je vois je vois pendant la
crise diamant ça va créer beaucoup plus
embouteillages mais bien à la réserve de
personnes va la respecter cette même
personne valeur
effectivement si vraiment il s'applique
cette loi là effectivement ça peut
mettre nos métiers ont dangereusement
pour jacques attali qui est motard en
plus un mais c'est vous avez un accident
voir mais j'ai pas eu d'accident sur
il devrait effectivement ils ont fait
découvrir de vélo c'est demain dans
paris qui font l'art dont pourrait
mettre de l on peut mettre un tracteur
un tracteur c'est stupide comprend un
bureau à d'abord le deux-roues pollue
moins que la voiture déjà pour commencer
les des deux roues électriques ils font
des lois dans tous les sens il continua
décision sur nivelle au centre
ce qu'il vient de faire une loi keynes
qui veulent servir à rien ou on prend
une moto pour effectivement aller plus
vite a affectivement entre ceux qui sont
allés ensemble pas que paris parce que
paris avait la panne était bon marché
il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'ils avaient
suscité des vocations
c'est une aberration effectivement quand
on prend la rue on a les pires notamment
sans que les terrils de il ferait mieux
de mettre à paris on avait des internés
entre effectivement des voitures et que
c'est aux voitures de respecter et faire
gaffe aux motos aux motards et pas et
palmer c'est une aberration totale
vraiment paris on a les pires isabelle
oui on a les pieds parce qu'on a une
belle bourde donc c'est vrai que les
pistes cyclables on peut récupérer faire
une voie et vous n'aimez pas née d'algos
que j'ai vu dans les jardins du tout
pourquoi parce qu'elle bétonne parce
qu'elle n'arrête pas de chez la maire de
paris anne hidalgo pour ceux qui savent
pas parce que j'aime bien je veux un
sondage elle a dit qu'elle allait
peut-être se présenter enfin ils ont
fait un sondage sur la présidentielle
est créditée de 6%
anne hidalgo heureusement parce qu'ici
on serait la mère dans toute la france
non mais c'est vrai mais j'ai rien
contre elle mais en même temps que la
critique mais elle est élue à chaque
fois mais oui mais là les élections à
paris c'est pas mal
les élections à paris c'est comme
comment je suis un jour légère il ya les
élections à paris on sait toujours pas
ce que c'est les conseillers municipaux
de castaldi chez plus il ya un bail site
off de trois verres si l'on doit le béa
sur mais bon voilà bon en tout cas elle
a été réélue c'est vrai à d'hidalgo mais
à d'hidalgo el hadj a flingué paris
puisque les bulles à la fois été sympa
mais alors il était sympa que tu fais
chier tout le monde a rigolé ça bon
alors je vous dis elle arrête pas de
dire qu'il faut être écolo la met sur
pause alors de ne pas dire qu'il faut
arrêter de couper des aides qu'il faut
replanter les arbitres au hac elle
commence par pas en coupe et c'est
vraiment les voix de l'est voire pour lé
pour les vélos c'est insensé
c'est plus large que voulez vous il ya
des moments où il ya personne sur les
boîtes gillot alors il y en aura
peut-être cet été mais il ya un
déséquilibre total
et quand elles désencombrer endroit
c'est pour plus l'encombré comme les
femmes de castaldi oui à laquelle il est
vrai il est vrai comme l'a dit guillaume
s'est pas tenable toute façon dans toute
façon cette laid mais l'album ou en
revanche aie aie aie oui vous l'aimez
bien aidé à lyon vous laisse un petit
coup non mais lui c'est sûr mais aussi
moi je bouffe à tous les râteliers avec
sans déconner bang il est surtout à
droite à gauche au milieu des papas
connais très bien
on connaissait tout le monde travers moi
y'a plein de gens que je connais très
bien je peux pas blairer
et là moi je suis bienveillant j'ai bien
aimé le voir sans devoir lui la peur de
2020 tu as peur qu'on lui reparle dès
qu'ils apprennent et à une concertation
avec la fédération française des motards
je crois actuellement où il proposait
une voie de gauche est limitée à 50
km/heure est-ce que ça ça vous convient
ou pas bravo même la mousson nous
convions de report soit mandat c'est
génial ça ça me conviendrait ces
renégociations encore pour courir sur
perry il pourrait très bien nous sommes
nous autoriser à continuer à faire les
remontées de files même on roule on a
trop tiré mes trains abaissée pas mal je
sais bien ralink jamais bernard super
atteindre son côté pas merci beaucoup
veulent en fait nivelles voulu faire la
guerre enfin c'est des restrictions pour
tout et en tout en fait on est dans un
pays où hormis liberticide pour les
motards
en fait ils veulent pas vous et vous il
va pas vous simplifier la vie je suis la
même manière qu'à la fin la guerre aux
automobilistes
maintenant il fait la bière au dos et
tous les fenêtres et murs et nationales
et national mais attention comme la
question les régions prix qu'il faut
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est une mission
pour les mots temps où est ce que c'est
pour remplir aussi les cas si on est ici
se mettre vraiment à nous sanctionner à
nous retirer des points mais déjà
financièrement nous personnellement on
va pas tenir
professionnellement on va perdre notre
travail parce qu'on n'aura plus de
permis n'a pas non plus je comprends pas
pourquoi tout ça m'étonnerait derrière
les pots d'échappement c'est tout aussi
dangereux que si vous des boîtes
même si on est passionné de rallye va
nous donner certainement une info non
non on risque d'avoir l'air idiot je ne
savais pas qu au ton nom c'est idiot de
la corde avec le genre masculin et
délirant foncés courts par hectare non
mais je ne savais plus que c'était
interdit par le code de c'était en
période de test en tout cas dans une
atroce le temps qu'il n'en faut combien
de temps à perdre il sait que c'est en
lisant l'info je ne savais pas que
c'était en période
tellement pour moi c'est normal est en
période de test
et ben non mais moi je ne sais je
mettrai en parlent ce soir eh bien oui
pour moi c'est tellement logique d'avoir
un deux roues et de se dire eh ben on
slalome entre les voitures mais on
remonte en slalom pas on est tellement
en tout cas pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui est logique ne comprends pas en tout
cas ils n'ont pas totalement interdits
ils ont dit qu'ils allaient y allait
avoir une expérimentation nouvelle
banque s'est figée à 90g le 1er février
interdite il est interdit pour ces
dernières une nouvelle expérimentation
d'ailleurs on est le pays s'arrête à
perdre et c'est fini c'est fini et donc
ça va arriver avec de france qu'à toute
la france oui mais c'est une ferrari
d'ailleurs ces trois départements comme
un département trois départements 3 oui
guillaume et stéphane disait de toute
façon ce sera pas respectée mais vous
rigolez
vous êtes hors la loi d'abord à trois
raisons - à chaque infraction à la
raison respecter la loi excusez moi là
même si c'est loin mais nul n'est
au-dessus de la loi beckham je suis poli
vais je suis retrouvé des corvées goût
personne n'est au-dessus de la loi
mais quel intérêt à ce moment là qu'elle
m'a vexé 2,2 points dans deux roues et
de stationner dans les canaux qui a les
intérêts de l'argent ça deuxièmement moi
c'est mon métier je suis bon et 500 ou
600 taxis motos dans paris ça veut dire
quoi on a acheté des véhicules à 35000
euros
on est là pour vous satisfaire hexacore
les gens en général qui sont pressés ou
marche et on seront fait quoi alors on
va perdre également notre travail par à
la brasse 1 je vais vous dire il ya
beaucoup de réactions il ya mon ami
raymond raymond qui nous écrit le
problème c'est les bouffons en 125 qui
n'ont pas leur permis moto ça c'est
vraiment qu'il y sera notamment à michel
louiset requis 10 et les mecs en deux
roues qui tordent des rétroviseurs ou
qui donne des coups de pieds dans les
voitures qui arrivent se croit
prioritaires saison pas fait j'espère un
coup de provisions dans la portière
c'est soit parce qu'ils sont comme ça
avec leur téléphone et qui a vu la
voiture elle dévie et tuant même en
klaxonnant et bien le métier ne suis pas
y aller mais c'est la dame qui rentrent
en train de se maquiller dans sa voiture
où c'est encore pire j'ai croisé tiffany
besson quand vous faites le petit truc
avec le pied moi j'adore
on va voir comment s'est jamais caché
oui à 56% non à 44% voyous passé assez
comme ça c'est partager mais il ya 56 %
des gens qui disent oui en tout cas
merci stéphane et stéphane des deux
réservoirs mai
on